[Musique]
du jour au lendemain elle est devenue le
visage canadienne une crise sanitaire
sans précédent des risettes à morandi
vedette l'épithète ne vient pas
naturellement quand on observe la
discrète docteur 99 est une menace pour
la santé publique
tous les canadiens droit va devenir
prend les métiers l'appropriation l'air
sérieux quelle que soit la tribune elle
livre d'un ton calme et posé les faits
bruts guide est d'abord et avant tout
par la science
originaire de rancune diplômé en
médecine au royaume uni c'est à
l'université de l'alberta qu'elle fait
sa résidence en pédiatrie
c'est durant un séjour de recherche en
colombie-britannique qu'elle développe
une passion pour les virus et les
bactéries la grippe devient l'un de ces
micro-organismes préféré comme l
explique dans cette entrée à la civis
mais son véritable intérêt pour la santé
publique se développe à la fin des
années 90 vingt ans plus tard l'enquêté
est devenue la chef d'un état major
sanitaire qui a essentiellement mis tout
un pays en confinement vaches ces images
elle compte à son actif une cinquantaine
de publications scientifiques agit comme
experte auprès de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
et participez à la lui
contre l'influenza l'ebola la
poliomyélite et le syndrome respiratoire
aigu sévère en 2003 une crise qui a
incité un tahoua a créé le poste
d'administrateur en chef de la santé
publique
elle est aujourd'hui la troisième
titulaire du titre mais la première
femme pouvoir dire quels il a doctor de
tous les canadiens
et derrière cette passion pour la santé
publique demeure encore cet amour des
enfants qui a marqué ses débuts en
médecine cause ou un sit in au salut de
tocane bonjour gré son but traverser la
tempête le plus calmement possible une
chanson à la fois oui oui oui oui